what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and before the writers and actor strikes
started Marvel Studios and Sony had
really started to get the ball rolling
with Spider-Man 4. and no unfortunately
I'm not talking about Toby Maguire
Spider-Man 4. although there have been
rumors that that might happen at Sony
but we are talking about the next Tom
Holland Spider-Man trilogy in fact not
too long before the strikes happened Tom
Holland came out and said that he had
met with Sony a few times and that what
he had seen so far what he had read and
what they had discussed as far as what
the story is going to be for Spider-Man
4 5 and 6 and the story with Spider-Man
in the King Dynasty and Avenger Secret
Wars was really good he really liked it
then the strikes happened and everything
got put on hold however as it turns out
we actually know quite a bit about what
is going to happen in Spider-Man 4 plus
the future of Spider-Man including when
he's going to be getting that Venom
symbiote suit and luckily some insiders
have revealed some information about
Spider-Man 4 and the future of
Spider-Man very recently so we have a
lot of new and exciting things to
discuss today for the future of
Spider-Man and we'll start with this
contract you probably know this but for
those who may not Tom Holland has
reportedly renewed his contract to play
in six more MCU projects three of which
we know are going to be the new
Spider-Man trilogy four five and six two
of them are also going to be the next
two Avengers films and there's one that
we don't really know about yet this
could be a cameo in another movie
perhaps Captain America 4 since it's
said to start the new Avengers team or
you could pop up in a show maybe maybe
in Daredevil we're unsure about that but
the great news is we're getting a lot
more Spider-Man now as far as the
release date is concerned unfortunately
there isn't an official release date set
right now however the cosmic circus
reported earlier this year that they
could release the movie sometime in July
of 2024 or June because right now Sony
has an unconfirmed Marvel project set to
release on June 7th 2024 which could be
Spider-Man 4 because this would have it
appearing in the MCU between Captain
America 4 Brave New World and the
Thunderbolts movie and as I mentioned
there is one project that Spider-Man is
going to appear in that we're unsure of
yet but that could be Captain America
Brave New World because again it's said
that the new Avengers are going to start
to form in that movie and who does Sam
know right now well he knows Spider-Man
he doesn't really know She-Hulk he
doesn't know Moon Knight he doesn't know
Echo he doesn't know Daredevil there's
only a select amount of people that he
knows in the MCU right now who are main
Heroes and Spider-Man's one of them so
this could be the movie that he appears
in and that could go directly into
Spider-Man 4 and remember Sam still does
know who Spider-Man is he just doesn't
know who Peter Parker is he doesn't know
that Peter Parker is Spider-Man but
everyone still knows who Spider-Man is
they just don't know his identity so
Spider-Man is still going to be with the
Avengers and from what we've heard
Spider-Man 4 is actually going to have
Tom Holland in his mask most of the time
that's also coming from a report from
the cosmic circus stating that his
personal life Peter Parker's personal
life that is is going to take kind of a
back seat to Spider-Man's life the
hero's life which makes sense because
again nobody knows who Peter Parker is
so how can he have a personal life if
none of his old friends or people he
cared about know who he is however of
course there have been reports that
Miles Morales is going to be entering
the MCU and that could be in Spider-Man
4. first and foremost Sony has already
confirmed that they are indeed going to
do a live-action Miles Morales Amy
Pascal confirmed this Tom Holland has
also stated that he would love for this
to happen he said and I quote I would be
honored to bring Miles Morales into the
live-action world how we do that I don't
know but given the opportunity I would
jump at it so Sony has confirmed they
are doing a live-action Miles Morales
and Tom Holland said that he would love
to bring Miles Morales into the MCU and
to top it all off a report from The
Insider viewer Anon states that the plan
slash goal for Spider-Man 4 is to bring
Miles Morales into the MCU Peter would
meet him while shaken hosts no way home
and they'll buy Bond over the course of
the movie now it makes sense for a bunch
of different reasons to bring Miles
Morales into the MCU but one specific
reason is because we mostly believe that
after these next six movies and
especially after this new Spider-Man
trilogy Tom Holland will be done playing
Peter Parker Spider-Man in fact he's
already stated a couple of different
times that if he's super old still
playing Spider-Man then he's done
something wrong and that's basically him
speaking as an actor not stating
anything bad about Spider-Man but he did
say that he wants to pass the mantle on
to somebody else let a newer younger guy
come in and play him and Miles Morales
would be a really good Spider-Man
replacement it would be fresh it would
be new plus he would have been trained
and he would have already fought
alongside of our Peter Parker Tom
Holland Spider-Man The Insider film
Odyssey also reported that Miles Morales
will be in Spider-Man 4 and yes he will
be younger than Spider-Man so between
Sony's stating they're doing a live
action Miles Morales and Tom Holland
stating that he would love to do that
and a few insiders talking about it as
well it looks like the odds of Miles
Morales showing up in Spider-Man 4 are
relatively good now as far as who the
villains of Spider-Man 4 are going to be
it sounds like Marvel Studios is truly
going to build up to a real Sinister Six
not like Spider-Man no way home where we
got five villains almost six villains
and almost got a sinister six but we're
talking about an official Sinister Six
it won't officially and fully happen in
Spider-Man 4 but it looks like that's
what they're going to build up to in a
report from the cosmic circus which has
been backed up by other insiders as well
they state that Kingpin Mr negative
Craven and Scorpion are the villains of
the film and recently my time to shine
hello has also stated that scorpion will
be in Spider-Man 4. now The Insider
can't we get some toast has stated that
Spider-Man 4 is going to kind of be a
sequel to the Hawkeye series and what I
presume that means is it's kind of going
to be a story about Kingpin we know that
in Daredevil Born Again Kingpin is going
to be running for and will become the
mayor of New York City so now you have a
Crime Boss who's the mayor of New York
City who's going to be doing some shady
and bad things well Spider-Man is truly
going to become the friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man so expect to see
him fight a lot more Street crime and
that of course means him running into
people who work for Kingpin and then
Kingpin himself which also means there
is a good possibility that Daredevil
could also make a cameo in Spider-Man 4.
considering how Daredevil born again is
going to focus on Kingpin being the
villain and since Kevin feige has
already mentioned that we are going to
have a street level Avengers team we're
assuming that since these two heroes are
fighting street level crime they'll
eventually interact with each other
which of course is what everybody wants
to see now in Spider-Man 4 we're not
going to get the full sinister six but
it does seem like Marvel Studios is
going to build up to that possibly for
Spider-Man 5 or Spider-Man 6. there's
speculation that Spider-Man 5 could
introduce Norman Osborne and we could
get him as the Green Goblin especially
since Spider-Man ran into him and
Spider-Man no way home but of course it
wasn't from our universe but that could
ultimately lead up to a Spider-Man 6
giving us a full Sinister Six with
Kingpin the Green Goblin Mr negative
Craven and Scorpion plus maybe Venom we
know that Spider-Man 5 and Spider-Man 6
are going to come after Avengers Secret
Wars according to the cosmic circus
Spider-Man 4 will come before Avengers
King Dynasty but the rest Spider-Man 5
and 6 will come after Secret Wars
because Marvel Studios basically does
not have a slot to throw it in before
Secret Wars it's possible but if they do
I'd be surprised especially if you
consider the reports that we've heard
that state Spider-Man is actually going
to be getting the Venom symbiote in true
comic origin fashion Spider-Man
originally got his black symbiote suit
in the secret War Story and thanks to
the post-credits scene for Spider-Man no
way home that showed Tom Hardy's Eddie
Brock Venom going back to his Universe
they kind of slapped Us in the face
there making us think that Tom Hardy's
Eddie Brock was going to go face to face
with Tom Holland Spider-Man but anyways
when he went back he did leave a piece
of the Symbiote behind showing us that
the Venom symbiote now does exist in the
MCU and is most likely going to find
Spider-Man eventually since this was
indeed the Spider-Man no way home post
credit scene but apparently he's not
going to be getting the Symbiote in
Spider-Man 4 they're going to wait to do
it in secret Wars so Spider-Man 5 could
be about Venom and ultimately that could
go into Spider-Man 6 leading Venom to be
a member of the Sinister Six and
Spider-Man might have some help taking
on the Sinister Six by Spider-Man 6 we
might have Miles Morales with Spider-Man
and Daredevil as well and that could
lead to a really interesting fight but
at the same time if it's his last movie
we'd almost like to see Spider-Man
himself take on the Sinister Six alone
but let us know what you think about all
of this in the comments down below the
future of Spider-Man is great right now
but is there something that you
specifically want to see Spider-Man do
in the MCU before Tom Holland is done as
Spider-Man let us know your thoughts
Down Below in the comments also don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest news and if you subscribe and
leave a comment you're out of
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick one winner at the end of
each month you can also find us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
foreign